I hope you're doing a lot better than me
I have very painful backs since
yesterday I was not even gonna have the
talk today because of that very I guess
I pinched my sciatic nerve or whatever
happened back there and I don't wish it
on on a relativist okay very painful
stuff I got some pillows behind me too
Kush in my back and today I was gonna
talk about mr. Michio Kaku one of my
favorites in fact I think he is my
favorite guy
my favorite mathematical what is it uh
comedian he's uh he's a stand-up
comedian that's what he is I have a lot
of fun with him I mean I don't know who
who listens to the guy like him who just
comes out with nonsense and more
nonsense and more nonsense so I love the
guy in uh I'm gonna I hope you take a
rain check and I'll talk about him next
time I don't want to have him you know
fade away okay today I'm going to talk
about a different subject because it
popped up with a comment and then a
couple more comments that came around
and I thought I'd clarify all these and
so here's the first comment that came up
follow says says which you think comes
first extinction or the establishment
acknowledging the Rope hypothesis okay
yeah he's a clown huh
very good question yeah I got a ready
answer for that I'm gonna place my bet
on extinction okay
the chances of the rope model hitting
the streets out there are next to nil
today and that's because there's so much
power in the mathematical hands one and
second is so widespread
too much inertia you just can't get a
through there because people are
convinced of black holes Big Bang
Dark Matter they've been drilled to
exhaustion on all this stuff you can't
take it all back from you know from
night to day that quickly it does it's
not going to happen real quick whatever
and I don't think it's gonna happen at
all all we can do is try and whoever
listens listens that's it that's all you
can hope for and it's a shame and as far
as I'm concerned not because of its my
theory I don't care about all that stuff
I don't care about monuments all that
nonsense no it's just be nice if people
when extinction comes at least they have
these views of how the universe might
work in a different way and yeah one of
the questions people sometimes ask me
how I got involved with the extinction
issue you know I mean if you're doing
physics what does extinction really have
to do with physics you could say it's
maybe a branch of paleontology and
paleontology is a branch of physics well
you know I've you know many moons ago I
thought we were gonna go out into space
we're gonna go to Mars then from there
on to the stars and then conquer the
galaxy you know I had this idea that so
many people still have out there and
then I came across Carl Sagan and say
can you know rubbed it in even more you
know we got terraform Mars and so on
billions and billions and you know I
love this stuff and I really at the time
I believed I gotta show my face in shame
yeah I believed we were gonna go out to
the stars
but then there was the issue of Fermi's
paradox you know and you had also the
issue of youth UFOs people like want
donek and bringing you know the notion
that extraterrestrials visited the earth
in the past I never believed in that
nonsense
but there was the issue for me paradox
you know where are the aliens aside from
the other side of the border right now
where are the you know how come we don't
have any any extraterrestrials yeah I
know
no one visited us no one has visited us
and we have to answer this we have to
figure that this is a valid question
and there are several answers to that
question one of them is that you know
they know we're here
the extra tour they're so superior to us
they know we're here
but they have this this notion this
ethical notion that like like we would
if we found life on Mars or whatever you
know we we wouldn't destroy it we
wouldn't kill it we would say hey you
know it's ethical let's let's let them
live you know we're superior they're
inferior let's let them live that sort
of thing another one is that you know
we've never been found by an
extraterrestrial civilization and
there's the other issue you know that
for those who believe in the Big Bang
you know here we are maybe at the
cutting edge of this expansion and for
all we know we could be the most
advanced civilization in the universe
you know so so there are many answers to
that question and my answer eventually
became well because we become extinct
okay and one of the guys that started
looking at going out into the universe
especially to other stars was this guy
Marc Millis he worked for NASA and he
was in the we call it the breakthrough
project something about the but I can't
remember full the exact name but it it's
a NASA project that ran for like seven
years and they finally shut it down and
they were studying the possibility of
traveling to the nearest star and they
finally gave up and this guy mark knows
now
has his private corporation where he he
still does Studies on going to the stars
and obviously you know this breakthrough
will never come and so the issue here is
that relativists book after book that I
read of relativist they all said hey
we're gonna go to the stars
and you know I started questioning that
I started saying you know are we gonna
go to the stars ever I mean if the
nearest art is 4.3 light years away you
know round trip is nine years running
off and even assuming we go what for are
we gonna explore are we gonna put a
colony there are we going to exchange
goods and services through 4.3 light
years distance so there was a problem
with with this notion of colonizing
another star system and then I brought
it even further home you know closer to
home and I said well are we even going
to colonize Mars and the issue there
again was you know what for I mean are
we gonna produce potatoes and apples in
Mars and bring him to earth exchange him
with the earth kind of expensive carrots
there you know no I realized that was
never going to happen and you know
digging deeper I came to the issue of
extinction and that's more or less
somewhat of the subject I'll be touching
today to some degree okay but it's not
gonna be directly involved with that you
know so I started getting involved with
also the issue of demander thoughts how
did the Neanderthals disappear how did
the how did wooly disappear how did the
Anasazi disappear how did the Clovis
people disappear the Mayans there are
these civilizations and groups they
disappeared and to the state nobody give
you a rational answer so I started
investigating that issue I'm saying well
let's see yeah I'm gonna give it a try I
want to find out you know how they
disappear because I just want to know
from my own
hey and I came to a totally different
conclusion all these folks especially
when you know if you are aware than last
4050 years I'd say even more than that
there's been a struggle
everybody in paleontology who studied
Neanderthals they they believed and
still believe that humans had something
to do with the disappearance of
Neanderthals and the more I got into the
subject tomorrow I realized for my sake
you know I came to the conclusion that
we have nothing at all to do with the
extinction of the Neanderthals and so we
have a clash of theories ok
and what do these people say well first
it was war then we out competed them
there was this fight between the wharf
action and the out competing faction you
know and they couldn't reach an
agreement but it had to do with us we in
the reason they concluded that we had
something to do with this is that when
humans started entering into Europe
that's when am I about that time is when
the Neanderthals began to disappear or
disappear completely and so they said
well we had something to do with it
obviously we came in they went out
straightforward right and I reached a
different conclusion that the only
reason we were able to enter Europe is
that finally is that any group that ever
entered Europe any human we will call
them krama cro-magnons or a pro mignon
any cro-magnons that came into europe
they were slaughtered by the and of
those that's why we didn't come into
Europe ok this was their territory
Europe was their territory they were
more or less sedentary in that sense we
were known nomadic we came from Africa
and it turns out you know we went to
Australia we went all the way east
20,000 years before we came to Europe so
we we went east all the way to places
like Australia we were there but we were
not
Europe and the only reason I can think
of is that the Neanderthals kept us out
if any group happened to man there you
know get lost into Europe they were
slaughtered immediately by the nanda
those and the only time we could finally
come in is when the Neanderthals were
rolling back they were starting to
become extinct that process began in
their world in their civilization and we
simply took over the caves over there
sites you know we found dead nanda
thoughts and so when this other theory
came around that Neanderthals had sex
with us and that was supposedly
confirmed in 2010 then I started looking
at this a little more deeply I knew that
was wrong there was something irrational
about that no we had no sex with a
Neanderthal and that's that's the
reigning theory today the reigning
theory is that they disappeared because
they had sex with us they were a smaller
population they kind of diluted into our
population and they got that through
genetic analysis yeah and that's
something of what I want to talk to you
about today okay so it comes at the
heels of another comment someone put up
here see if I can get it in here okay so
as two species are different if they
cannot interbreed in the wild that was
my statement this guy says this
statement is simply incorrect whoa or
are you asserting that donkeys and
zebras dogs and wolves and lions and
tigers are not different species oh yeah
they are different species that's not
the part you should be challenging it
the part you should be challenging is
whether they can interbreed in the wild
that's the part that's that we have a
problem with okay not with the fact that
there are different species and you know
I wrote a book about the Neanderthal how
the Neanderthals disappeared and in it
I've got this this thing about the Red
Wolf war and that puts the geneticists
in the right
perspective okay and it turns out that
you know there was this red wolf that
seems or looks for appears to a lot of
people as being a hybrid between a
coyote and a wolf a gray wolf you know
some sex in the wild there and they use
that as an as an example of
interbreeding in the wild that's one of
the examples that are used to justify
that Neanderthals and humans interbred
in the wild and so I looked at the this
war that a lot of papers that were
written on it I wanted to get involved
with that and I did a real research on
it and these are the conclusions
essentially okay they raised an example
of interbreeding the wild the groups
what was the problem that well the red
wolf was becoming extinct there's only I
think today there's only about 300 red
wolves in the wild okay and some of them
are being bred purposely and thrown into
the wild okay
the law protects endangered species the
law does not protect hybrids and so the
question was whether the Red Wolf was an
original species a unique species or
whether it was a hybrid between the gray
wolf and a coyote okay because
apparently the red wolf has some
features of both okay so they finally
called in the geneticist forty years now
since 1980 and the red wolf question was
whether it was a species or a hybrid
after 40 years the geneticist after
doing all kinds of genetic analysis they
did a genome full genome on the Red Wolf
etc they still cannot reach an agreement
on whether it's a hybrid for us or a
unique species why is that important
well it's important because here we have
sponte Pavo from the Max Planck
Institute on you know his gang of
geneticists and these people tell you
without a shadow of a doubt that's
because that's the reigning theory today
that the Neanderthals disappeared when
they had sex with us
and that they determine this because
they did a genetic analysis genome and
several other analysis and empty DNA etc
Y chromosomes and so on and they
determined through genetic analysis that
because we have two to three percent
Neanderthal blood in us DNA right
that we had sex with them and that's how
they disappeared and here we have the
red wolf we have these these animals are
alive today they did all kinds of
studies and they can't reach an
agreement why can't they reach an
agreement well they can't reach an
agreement because you have two factions
the faction who says hey you should not
protect the red wolf screw him you know
he's just another gray wolf just a
variation of the gray wolf or maybe of
the coyote fur for all we know and the
other of the faction says look you know
this is this is an original species we
must protect it because the law protects
original specie endangered species and
so that each one brought their lawyers
each one brought their geneticists and
they can't reach an agreement for an
animal that's alive today and we have
all three animals we have the coyote we
have the gray wolf we have the red wolf
we have them all in front of us and the
geneticist cannot reach an agreement
there and they have this fistfight
because of politics and opinions but
here we have the geneticists of max
planck incident and they can tell you
without a shadow of a doubt that the
reason the Neanderthals won't be when
extinct is because they had sex with us
and they determined that through genetic
analysis so yeah I got a problem with
that geneticists are overstepping the
bounds there they're putting their
beliefs in knew of science that's what
they're doing they're not doing any
research what they're doing is just
telling you their beliefs and so yeah I
got a problem with that because no
animals have sex in the wild no no two
different species have sex in the wild
even if they could from a genetic point
of view more than likely they don't
because of cultural differences between
them they have their own clans or they
have this distrust out there in the wild
it doesn't happen and I cannot imagine
humans
venturing into Europe and suddenly you
being friendly with the Neanderthals hey
buddy you mind if I kill one of your
mastodons over here one of your mammoths
right you know all these animals though
especially hunters you know apex
predators they are territorial is they
are protective of their territory number
one okay
they also have their harems and that can
sort of thing okay we got protects that
jealously he's not gonna let another
clan Ananda thought that was not gonna
allow another Neanderthal in his
territory let alone a human and these
people are saying that we went there and
just said hey buddy let's have a beer
and that's AG let's trade wives you know
know these people whoever proposes that
Neanderthals and humans had sex has a
mental problem that's the way I treat
them means they don't know the first
thing about anthropology or paleontology
hasn't done any research whatsoever the
only thing he's done is read out thority
and take everything on the basis of
authority and the authority comes from
people like Svante Paabo and again his
group you know they come up with
nonsense and again to the three percent
what does that tell me
especially when they can't tell me
anything about the Red Wolf today how
can I believe what they're telling me
about something that happened 40,000
years ago with only two or three samples
so no no way
these people are just flushing their
religion down your throat when they say
that we had sex with the Neanderthals
and that's how they disappeared and
again the issue here was that under all
circumstances all just about I'd say 99
or 100 percent of the paleontologists
out there are convinced that humans had
something to do with this appearance of
the end of thoughts and I'm saying it
had they had nothing to do with it
absolutely nothing
the nandha thought died all on their own
they died with their population pyramid
overturned and were there when their
genetic diversity disappeared and that
happens towards the end of a species
life to all species
unless a mass extinction occurs before
that which is what's going to happen to
us
so I have a different mechanism I don't
need interbreeding to what is called
admixture to to show how the
Neanderthals disappeared and then again
the issue is if that's how the
Neanderthals disappeared
how did Heidelberg disappear before him
how did Homo erectus or antecessor it
disappear before them you know did we
kill those as well the Neanderthals kill
hydaburg
did they have sex with the Heidelberg is
that how the Heidelberg disappeared how
did the homo erectus disappear did
Heidelberg have sex with Homo erectus is
that how he disappeared or antecessor or
any of those other monkeys so so this
notion that a species disappeared
because it has sex it's just outrageous
it's because they don't have a a theory
for extinction that's what it is okay so
another issue that came up related very
closely related is this one that
troubles me tremendously and this guy
says the following says even in
so-called hunter-gatherer societies
there was trade when you create an
object eventually someone is going to
want to give you something for it my god
these people believe that Basel
hunter-gatherers were trading and lots
of people out there believe in this and
you'd say well because they don't know
they're not into paleontology they never
studied of Neanderthals we don't know
you know but no it's the research says
researchers say the same thing here you
have one statement these are all
thinking out of eluted you're out there
or out of articles okay one guy says
according to Peter Watson trait could
have begun a hundred and fifty thousand
years ago
unbelievable they're talking about trade
about exchange about Commerce existing a
hundred and fifty thousand years ago
here you have a paleontologist so-called
I don't think he's fit to sign a man's
shoes this guy should get out of
paleontology he knows nothing about him
paleontology and he says Neanderthals in
a couple of cases are trading shells
that came from fossil deposits and they
trade them over long distances
unbelievable that someone would say that
Betsy he considers himself a
paleontologist or anthropologists or
whatever to me that's an outrageous
statement coming from a guy who
supposedly studied anthropology or
paleontology or even geology and so on
unbelievable that they would make these
statements these people are introducing
things of today our service economy and
if they're implanting it in to the
Neanderthal or the Upper Paleolithic
world it doesn't even apply to us chroma
cro-magnons right
it doesn't even apply to us but they're
introducing these notions that we traded
and Ananda thought traded and now we
treated with an and earth oh we traded
seashells who knows for sex I don't know
for furs is that what we traded them for
well what would you trade them for okay
and I'll get to that in a second here
and here's another statement also you
can see these are all people who talked
about this these are all researchers and
says hand axes or stone tools they were
the first commodity axes may have been
traded between human groups and would
have served as social to two others says
the Chilean hand axe was standardized in
shape became exchanged in social
networks so what is this the internet or
something you know you can order it by
through the internet a marketable good
or service that has value again that
word value so dangerous everybody talks
about value and that shows you that he's
a Disneyland economist and is used as an
item for exchange so all these people
really believed that there was trade and
enters a lot more articles I mean I've
gone through lots of articles that basil
hunter gathers up
Palaeolithic you're talking about 40,000
years ago 40,000 years ago that is
cro-magnons cavemen Stone Age people
that they were doing trade and the first
thing you should note is that we hadn't
even invented the notion of a tribe
tribe comes many many moons later now at
the time all they had were clans small
groups maybe up to 2025 maybe I would
even give up to 50 which I doubt they
were relatively small groups family
members extended family members that
formed these clans and they would go out
there and kill some animal and live
another day that's the way it was some
followed the herds some found a little
niche where there were animals pastoring
regularly there maybe they stuck around
for a while they became semi sedentary
or semi-nomadic whichever we want to
look at it
but this is all we did for thousands and
thousands of years okay and to say that
these creatures traded whatever for
whatever well let me give you some
evidence here a few articles that you'll
read out there just to give you a notion
where I stand it at least on this and
here you have one says talking about the
Indians right in this case the Apaches
says each man made his own arrows and he
each man cut a branch from a tree and he
wanted to make sure that everybody knew
that that arrow or whatever the law in
that bow belonged to him it was a
personal item and he took pride in
having it and we're talking about
Apaches which were already built into
tribes okay and still the guy made his
own weapons not to mention a basil clan
caveman okay here the Pueblo Indians
same thing you'll see that this is what
people say out there the researchers say
each man made his own arrows okay
he took pride in making young besides he
had to learn how to make it because he's
not gonna exchange out there you know
with some other Indian who's he got
trade with the Sioux Indians with the
crow they would murder him before they
trade him
he doesn't trade his weapons or his
tools
here's another again another article
that says generally each man made his
own weapons bows and arrows each man
could recognize his own handiwork and
whether the reasons for that is the
arrows any character served as a means
of settling disputes of ownership which
often are owes after great tribal
buffalo hunt okay and here not just
talking about the American Indians
you'll you'll see this in every culture
wherever there were basal
hunter-gatherers their tools was a
personal item partly because he took
pride in making it okay and second
because he had to learn it since you
from the time he was a child he learned
it with his father typically with a with
someone in the family and and then he he
had to know how to use it since he was a
child he had to make it and use it and
so this thing about trading tools and
weapons no no and here's a final one on
that says again others use arrowheads as
a form of identification or a specific
feather design this enabled them to
determine who had killed a given animal
and claimed the quarry okay
again and it says it was necessary for
them to become expert marksman as well
as skilled manufacturers right and they
developed their skills in the use of
bows and arrows as children okay so if
this happened at the tribal level more
even more specific it happen at the
and level you built your own weapons you
made your own tools besides you know
here you have a stone tool you know you
use this the slower stone tool that you
maybe hit a piece of wood or whatever
you want to break or you have a sharp
piece of stone with which you cut meat
would you go out there on a road in the
middle of a you know forest the highway
that goes through the force you know put
your little stand and start selling you
know arrowheads spear heads to whoever
comes around you go to the other clan
and say hey guys you know I got arrows
so for sale ugh I'd like to buy some
furs or some meat for the arrow I mean
these people are idiots
these people whoever says that is an
idiot is a person who is not even in
touch he's got his feet off the ground
he's talking nonsense
there was no trade among basic
hunter-gatherers trade was invented many
moons many moons later in the Neolithic
there was no trade before the Neolithic
okay and if if these professionals have
not understood that much or never learn
that much rather than have the intuition
to understand so much they're in the
wrong field they should be shining shoes
clean with latrines with toothbrushes
that's what they should be doing they're
not qualified to do these kinds of jobs
these professions okay how about clothes
another issue you know did the
Neanderthal wear clothes here you you
see they show the nano-cells always
wearing clothes the documentaries always
show nano clothes wearing clothes I've
got a big problem with that you know I
mean I've never seen a mammoth wearing
clothes or socks or anything I underwear
I don't know about you Tigers I've never
seen them wearing clothes
why would nanda thought be different and
for this I can only give you my my view
my general view on this
this is the way I see things anything
that challenges this I'm not gonna
automatically deed I throw it away but
I'm gonna look at it very carefully
because this is the idea I have in my
head of how things progressed in the
evolution of man okay here's the our
family tree okay looks more or less like
this according to me okay this these are
the actual bones that we found so this
is the best we've got not that you you
got to take this with a pinch of salt
okay that's important habilis Homo
habilis he was there maybe 2.3 1.6
million years ago
plus or minus these numbers are very
very general so you know don't bet your
life on any of these numbers okay but
these are just ballpark figures okay you
get a look at him as such they had a
smaller brain we went from that stage to
the erectus stage from there perhaps in
Europe we had this other creature called
antecessor okay which is some kind of
evolution between erectus and Heidelberg
okay then came to Heidelberg then came
the Neanderthals who almost everyone
agrees descended from the Heidelberg
Heidelberg disappears and earth all
appears so there must have been some
kind of evolution between either Bergen
and earth oh and then we came and we
came from Africa okay this is the
general picture that I have in my mind
whether I'm right or wrong again you
know we have very small pieces of our
entire history we find a phone here
sometimes it's a tooth bone they have to
you know infer lots from that tooth okay
and so you got to be careful a lot of
paleontology is a very inexact science
in that sense all you have it's theories
based on the bones that they found you
know and you got to be very careful with
paleontology and let me tell you I am I
just try to use as much common sense
that I can put into the bones you know
once I see a bone uh a skull or whatever
I try to reach some kind of conclusion
from that as well you know and again
well I'm willing to change my mind a lot
of
stuff regarding paleontology some stuff
I'm not willing to okay and and here's a
couple maps that I put in my book in
fact in the Neanderthal book that I
wrote okay
these are maps that give you an idea how
I picture this whole this whole scenario
okay
we had Homo habilis we found very few
bones very few skulls and they're all in
Africa the Chinese today wanna claim
that man really started in Africa in
China they would love to say this but
there's no evidence that there's
anything older than Homo erectus in
China and we do have Homo erectus in
Africa that's the second graph there the
second map there and from there we can
believe that Homo erectus slowly went
first into Europe and then farther east
all the way into China and Indonesia and
all these other places out there okay
now the important thing to note here is
that Homo erectus went all the way to
Western Europe he was in France he was
in Spain and he was in England Germany
as well right and that was almost not
quite but almost a million years ago
800,000 years ago 700,000 years ago we
have evidence of some human-like
creature living in Western Europe and
why is that important well it's got to
do with this clothes thing you know
because we had arctic weather there in
fact it was colder than much colder and
today we had the Arctic sheets come down
all the way to England and these guys
were living in that environment and the
question is how did they live were they
wearing clothes no after thousands and
thousands of years they got used to the
cold just like wolves get used to the
cold just like bears get used to the
cold just like mammoths got used to the
cold
you put an elephant in the Arctic he
dies but the mammoths lived in the
Arctic
likewise you put a
in the Arctic gorillas will die but this
fella neanderthal he lived there and
before then we had Heidelberg living in
that environment before that we had
either antecessor or Homo erectus living
in that same environment did they have
clothes that they have sewing needles
too you know sew buttons or maybe
zippers no these were nude completely
they were they didn't even have shoes
sandals or anything under feet and you
say how can it possibly be well how can
a wolf
we have wolves that sleep in the slow
they sleep in the snow how do they do
that how does that dog live in in the
Arctic
he's got this layer of fat he's used to
the cold he can withstand that cold and
so good
Mandor thaw and Heidelberg so could
maybe antecessor Homo erectus so no
these animals these monkeys they did not
have clothes so I cannot imagine a
Neanderthal with clothes you know I mean
that's great for for Hollywood but not
in reality they had no clothes and no
shoes especially they walk directly on
the snow okay they were used it there
was their environment they got used to
it after thousands of years they had
this thick layer of fat underneath their
skin that protected them against the
cold these were completely nude animals
to dress him up is ridiculous but that's
what Hollywood does and yeah from there
we went to this Heidelberg man and in
fact before then we probably have
antecessor
now from there we have this map that's
on the right and the only thing I want
to mention to you there is that
Neanderthals the ones that are in
Western Europe in Spain France Germany
and England
not so much England but those other
three countries they differed from those
in the Middle East the brown area there
they have different morphological
characteristics and there's debate still
on whether all of those can be called
Neanderthals that's why I don't put them
as nano thought I laid
them as archaic humans and the same with
those that are in Italy and Yugoslavia
Yugoslavia you know all those countries
there you know the Neanderthals that
supposedly were there I'm not even sure
they're Neanderthals okay that's got to
be you know established first they could
have been related I'm not saying that
they weren't but they do have different
morphological characteristics you should
be aware of that at least that not all
paleontologists agreed at all of these
are Neanderthals from Western Europe all
the way to the Middle East
no there's there are significant
differences between them
okay so just be aware of that that the
jury is still out on that subject okay
so here's here's our family tree we
probably started 200,000 years maybe at
most three hundred thousand years ago
that's when our species came into being
what I mean by that is that if you take
a person today okay that's what I mean I
want you to be clear on what I mean by
species you take a human today and you
took them you know through the time
tunnel 200 maybe 300 thousand years ago
he could still have sex with one of our
ancestors there you know our forefathers
and have viable children that's what I
mean by species if you go 300 and 1000
years you just step over that line that
other monkey there you can't have
children with that any more viable
children so it's like that's what I call
a species when when you can no longer
breed with that fellow 300 maybe 400
thousand years ago that's that's a
different species now because you've
isolated yourself so much from that
trunk that you're a different species
and so here we have what we could say is
the lineage for man
these are skulls that we did find which
are similar to man and
you could build to some degree a an
evolution chart from this we have your
hood man 300 thousand years ago we have
two hundred thousand years the Omo man
and adult to about 150 thousand years
ago okay and these are more or less what
we think were the predecessors of man we
consider these guys all Heidelberg level
type people we call them Rhodesian man
okay
known as Rhodesian man man of Rhodesia
these are general names that are given
out there remember we have very very
very few samples there may be ten
samples of and we got a build a story
from these it's like building a puzzle
you know they give you a puzzle to to
build and they only give you like five
pieces you got to determine you know
what the puzzle looks like you know
maybe maybe it's the Eiffel Tower maybe
it's the the Chinese wall for all you
know I mean you could come up with
almost anything because you only have
very few pieces and so you know there
are very many theories on you know what
possibilities could have been there so
this is just a general thing and I build
my my opinions my theories from these
bones and from what I read in the
literature out there you know I take
everything with a pinch of salt
paleontology
pinch of salt you can't take anything
you can't put your hand in the fire for
anything now you talk to you very very
little except maybe the objective there
like if you found the bone well yeah
that's objective but whatever
interpretation you give that that's
that's up to debate okay okay so uh what
happened when Ando felt on his sac whoa
Nano suffered a tremendous evolution in
the last hundred years he suffered a
tremendous evolution I mean this is how
Neanderthal was pictured at the
beginning of the century 1909 French guy
had an artist he commissioned an artist
to draw Neanderthal from the bones that
he had and this is what he came up with
and you can see what happened over the
years you know Neanderthal suffered
Bendis evolution by the time we get to
2013 he's a movie actor blonde and you
know blue eyed and I went to the
Neanderthal Museum here up north in
Germany in 2015 I took that picture
there and the guys even dressed you know
they they they have not only does he
look human he's he's he's dressed like a
he looks like a Salesman now I would
trade with this guy no doubt about it
right and so the question is you know a
woman would probably have no problem
sleeping with a guy in 2013 I'm
wondering if a woman would suite with a
guy in 1909 you know I mean are we the
same species and after so many thousands
of years of divergence where you know in
the end athough was like five hundred
thousand it was born maybe five hundred
thousand years ago and we were born in
African a totally different environment
maybe three hundred thousand years ago
we met 200 maybe 250 thousand years
later after humans ventured into into
Europe could we have made it assuming we
made it I could we have had viable
children
I mean after such separation and what
are the clues that we have for that is
that we have no mitochondrial DNA that
means we have no and no human today has
any mitochondrial DNA and that's been
shown at least nine reports nine
articles that were published there's no
there's no affinity between us and
female and rickles yeah we should have
inherited some empty DNA from them they
find all kinds of excuses why we don't
have it we have no white chromosomes no
man alive today has y chromosomes from
man and Earth all's and Y chromosome is
inherited from the father passed on from
father to son
no human today no human males today has
any y chromosome from any agatha father
so we had no Neanderthal fathers we had
no Neanderthal mothers but we had sex
with these people and that's how they
disappeared
yeah sure sounds reasonable okay and
here's a comparison I want you to tell
me if what you think I mean this is the
way I look at things these are the
skulls of a Neanderthal and a cro-magnon
okay I hope you can tell which one is
which okay two distinct features the
eyebrows of the Neanderthal and a lack
of chin Nando those don't have chins we
have chant we invented the chin there
are no monkey before us had chin okay
and yeah I don't know you might say well
the Neanderthal on the upper left that's
an exaggeration so is the guy in the
middle at the bottom there
yeah maybe these are exaggerations
people come up with different ideas of
what they think the Neanderthals looked
like but the skulls don't lie and the
skulls show that there was a great
difference between them another thing
you should be aware of is that the you
know the the notion out there and and
the documentaries reinforce that notion
is that we were tall and they were short
that's BS okay Neanderthals were about
five point five feet five on the average
and we were five feet six bro magna was
about five feet six we were just about
an inch on the average right honey
Everage we were about one inch taller
than neighborhood that's it they were
all small in fact if you go through with
cokes law as it's known species become
taller and taller over time call this
people live today people in Holland and
the blue seas in southern Africa these
are the tossed people today and and and
we became taller and taller and taller
over time if you go to the Hollanders of
a thousand years ago they were neat not
half as tall as we are today okay they
were a lot smaller not only have we
increased our life our longevity our
lifespans but we have also increased our
sizes that's known as coops law all
species tend to do that in general
except you know
that are stuck in Islands called island
dwarfism okay so nano-cells were small
and they died small five five feet five
and cro-magnons that entered were five
feet six so this notion that we were a
hit one head taller than nanda those
that's wrong and that we were we were
definitely weaker than they were they
were built like monkeys okay they were
big broad you look at their chest their
their whole ribcage much wider
especially at the bottom wider than
humans it's totally different animal
this is a totally different animal it's
like saying that you had sex with a
gorilla or a chimpanzee no no such thing
in fact we try to create a human Z cross
between a human females who who were
willing to do the crossover and no no
chance no humans II never happened they
they have so many when you read the
literature you have to be so careful
with these people because they put a lot
of their personal opinions or foregone
conclusions and they put them out there
as proof and truth as fact and one of
those is you know when when we started
using weapons you know and you can only
go by the record what actually what you
actually find because that's objective
and this is one of the weapons the one
we use for a long long time and it was
the spear okay and probably the original
spear was like that one in the center
with just a pointed stick and then
eventually we stuck a stone sharp stone
at the end of it okay and the ones on
the right were found in a cave in
shunning in and those are dated to about
400,000 years ago okay these are the
first Spears that we have now one thing
I want you to notice that they're made
out of wood and one of the claims today
is that we don't find other things
because you know wood doesn't preserve
well well those Spears are well
preserved and they lasted 400,000 years
so I think a lot of that is a cop-out
if you don't see something made out of
wood which you suspect that there that
someone in the past had you better start
doubting at first start by doubting
first and then see if you can prove the
opposite to yourself okay but it's good
to have objective data and this was
objective 400,000 years ago more or less
that's how the cave was measured as far
as longevity and that's where they found
the Spears and the spears do look old
okay so you can more or less at least
use it as a foundation for any theory
and saying look apparently there were
spears four hundred thousand years ago
why am I saying this because there's a
theory and here I'll put it up here that
the first bow and arrow when did that
come into being when did we invent the
bow and arrow and so there's a claim by
a research team that sixty two thousand
years ago in a cebu to cave in south
africa you'll find this article several
places of people quoting it etc they
found these these sharp what appeared to
be arrowheads and maybe they were
arrowheads personally I have doubts I
have doubts because there's no arrow
with the arrowheads that's the first one
and again the acclaim is well wood
doesn't survive well I just saw a spear
that beats this by three hundred
thousand years at least and that wood
survived but here we don't see any wood
all we see is the arrowheads okay that's
the first one second the one you see on
the bottom there on bottom left they're
all elongated which would indicate to me
that they were probably used for Spears
and not so much for arrows okay
the first definite proven bow and arrow
this is a bow the one on the right and
that was dated to 18,000 years ago and
Manheim focused on and so this you can
put your hand in the fire for but the
one on the left is just a clean another
problem I've got with the one on the
left is that you know if we invented bow
and arrow 62 thousand years ago why did
we enter Europe with Spears instead of
with bows and arrows and
hunt mammoths and whatever with bows and
arrows from the distance I mean if we
had invented bows and arrows and we had
him around for us in sixty two thousand
years ago how did we enter Europe 40 40
but really thirty five thousand years
ago because again that's another issue
you know when we entered Europe
how did we enter Europe with Spears why
did we enter it with spear why didn't we
enter with the bow and arrow and start
shooting and yeah the first human that
we definitely dated gay in Europe is in
Romania and what is it estera ikuo ace
and that's the first cro-magnon you can
say found in Europe that the oldest
skeleton all the others are
interpretation so be very careful what
you read out there okay there's claims
that they found like a forty thousand
year old man cro-magnon man in England
and there's always this debate on
whether in fact they didn't find a man
they found like a tooth and they say oh
this this belonged to a human and
there's the debate whether it belonged
to human or a Neanderthal and so on
there so a lot of those don't put your
hand in the fire for those but in in the
case of hysteria cool ways yeah they
found a skeleton that's the oldest
skeleton we've got today and that's all
you can do you know that's the best you
can do and say look apparently humans us
you know our forefathers entered Europe
sometime maybe around 35,000 years ago
why is that important because the
musterion
technology the ones that the
Neanderthals used from beginning to end
disappeared 40,000 years ago so we can
so according to the evidence right if
we're just gonna go with objective
evidence humans the the first human
appears 35,000 years ago the last the
end of them disappeared 40,000 years ago
there was a five-year thousand-year
difference now I don't think it was that
that clear-cut all I'm saying these this
gives you an idea that you
it's kind of entered after the
Neanderthals were gone that's a better
conclusion than saying then oh we
intermingle with them for 10,000 years
as the paleontologists tell you today
and we had sex during that time and and
a little while they disappeared and all
that remained was us yeah there's a lot
of problems with that theory from
several angles and I just can't treat
them here I did treat them in my book
but I can't it's just no time to go over
each fine point of why that's not even
close okay and another issue is when did
we start eating vegetables veggies were
we always carnivores did we always eat
meat just meat or did we supplement our
diet with veggies okay and that's kind
of important also because the question
is you know a lot of people again say
well you know food does a veget vet
vegetables they do not survive whereas
well meat doesn't survive that matter
either but we have a good idea that
those spears were not used for hunting
lettuce yeah they were used for happy
animals but people say and specially
today where we have more and more
vegetarians in our world a lot of these
people want to show that humans have
always been vegetarians and I've got a
little problem with that I'll tell you
why here in a second okay so here let's
go over the first one this is an article
I can get it up here one article that
comes out there that tries to prove this
group of ladies especially and I'm sure
they're all vegetarians and says an
ancient grinding stone found in grown up
ugly Chia this is in Italy okay and says
it's that stone at the bottom of pestle
okay and says that the scientists
discovered that some of the debris on
the stone turns out to be none other
than oatmeal the Grove Asian people
heated the grains before grinding them
with the stone in order to preserve and
prep them for processing the resulting
powder was then made into bread and
oatmeal well I don't know I have a lot
of problem with this now the
it's the first thing you have to be
careful is about the dates says 33,000
to 21,000 years ago and they try to push
it as far back as they can always when
they publish their articles and they say
look it's 33,000 years ago we were
making bread I got a big problem with
that okay got a big problem why because
what they show here this pestle okay and
what they found is those little things
that you see on the top those were seen
under a SEM those pictures were taken
and what they say is those are remnants
of oatmeal okay and they compare them
against what you see on the bottom in
red those are the modern-day versions of
those same oatmeal so they say look we
found them under stone so obviously they
were grinding these these oats and they
ate them and they probably made bread
with them so they took a big step you
know in in their reasoning
they went from finding a little speck of
oat from there they said well they've
been grinding this the this they heated
them they they kind of because they they
turn them into like ashes and they
somehow ate them directly or they made
bread with them this 33,000 years ago
right after the Neanderthals went away
and we started conquering Europe hey let
me tell you why I've got problems with
that and about let's continue because
first I got to show you that what people
right and now I'll tell you what's wrong
with it okay here's another and these
groups are all related by the way okay
so that the Neanderthals okay they had
they were cooking foods although we
found no pots and pans you know there's
no pots and pans from the Neanderthals
but these people are talking about not
only cooking but boiling like maybe they
did it in water maybe they made soup
with it that's that's what these people
are suggesting okay and why do they
believe this they found calculus in the
teeth of Neanderthals and again the
Stanton and Ethel's are primarily from
the east shanidar okay maybe the one in
Belgium and the questions whether all of
these Fernando those that's one issue
but the question is because they found
calculus in the thief they say the that
shows that they ate veggies okay this
this is the reasoning okay based on what
they see in you know in the tooth enamel
that they analyzed okay
okay another one uh third one here again
along the same lines and by the way it
comes from the same people it seems like
the same people are trying to push this
theory but see this lady Maria Mario de
l'épée up there that you see on the
upper left Martha Martha Lippe okay she
does a lot of work on this and she
pushes her theory that you know they
veggies in the old days and I just want
to point out what you see at the bottom
which comes from this report from this
paper says the starch grains recovered
on these objects appeared to be mostly
of cattail and fern both of these are
rich in starch and as such they
represent a significant source of
carbohydrates and energy and the
autherine analysis of how much energy
they got the our ancestors got out of
all this okay says but Batra comb moon
works hey fern that was widespread
around the site and is characterized by
starch rich rich root that is easy to
grind so they found not only a fern but
they found this cattail and I said what
the hell is a cattail I mean never heard
of it you know and so I looked it up and
here's here's what a cattail is okay and
remember they they had to burn this
thing they had to put it on in the fire
for some reason right that's what they
say and they say they ate this stuff
made flour from it here it is this is
what a cattail
does and looks like it's a plant that
you open up and has all this fuzz in it
okay and the question is whether they
ate this stuff or maybe they use it for
all I know they're they use it to
make pillows maybe for the baby maybe
they put the baby in there yeah yeah for
all I know I mean we don't know what the
context was to say that they ground this
stuff to eat it and make bread with it I
think is a long shot
and when you put that together with the
other idea that you know nobody eats
ferns humans don't eat we don't eat
ferns but animals mammals don't eat
ferns you know there's some very rare
animals that eat a fern a special type
of firm they got used it over the
centuries or millennia you've got some
insects that may meet some parts of
ferns but ferns are not part of
anybody's diet today and to say that and
so if they ground ferns where they are
ancestors
eating ferns well if they were eating
ferns how come we don't eat firms today
I mean we should have had this culture
were today you know would have evolved
into fern eating then another issue that
you don't find any mortars mortar is the
the bowl where you know you have this
pestle and you ground whatever nuts
whatever you want to pound into a powder
you ground them in the mortar and there
are no mortars all you find are the if
anything the pestles if that's what it
was and yeah you can use the pestle to
ground a lot of stuff the question who
was that for eating or was that to make
bed sheets I mean I don't know why were
they burned why do we always find them
like burn is it because they cooked them
and ate them or is it because they
softened them up for for some other
purpose maybe to use as beds I mean
there could be different interpretation
especially when you know you would not
eat the stuff normally okay I don't
think anybody goes out there and starts
eating one of these so-called weeds it
could have happened but again all I'm
saying you got to be very careful what
you read because these people put this
stuff out there as truth in fact and you
got to be very careful with paleontology
on on
in fact okay and there's a again just
like there is a tendency to say that
Neanderthals disappeared because they
have sex with us and that's the theory
and you got to swallow it because that's
what we proven got to be very careful
with that you gotta be careful with
people saying oh we found the first bow
and arrow we found the first vegies that
people ate you know here you have these
nomadic hunter-gatherers gathers I don't
know how much they gather maybe fruit
and nuts
I can accept because it's readily eaten
but to say that you go out there and get
some weed and you grind it and you make
flour and you make bread man that's a
long shot that's that's that's taking
your reasoning quite a bit and they
start talking about how much energy that
would give I I don't give a damn about
that who cares about the energy could a
hunter would a hunter prefer to eat you
know some weed that he ground which he
knew nothing about a rule or kill an
animal for which he had already a
history of hunting and killing it
besides more exciting than hunting you
know oats in the field you don't go
hunting for oats besides you know you
would have to get tons of oats grind
them in order to produce a little you
know piece of bread no no I don't think
it ever happened the other issue is that
you know these guys went nomadic and
they they couldn't take too much stuff
with them they didn't have backpacks and
good shoes and all that stuff so they
couldn't carry tons of material whatever
they found they found wherever they came
maybe they went into a cave to seek
protection from the cold or from animals
and so whatever they took were usually
their weapons that's it would they take
a pistol a pistol and a mortar and start
grinding wheat out there in the middle
of nowhere I don't know I have trouble
with that and the other issue I have
trouble with is there's 20,000 years
between what these people say which is
30:33
years ago to the time when we really
find mortals and pistols which is closer
to the end of the Paleolithic and almost
at the dawn of the Neolithic that's
where we start finding these things
20,000 years to invent the mortar no I
have problems with all that there's a
lot of problem with that especially when
they have such different dates again
weapons gives you an idea how could they
have invented bows and arrows in South
Africa sixty-two thousand years ago and
walk into Europe twenty five thousand
years a thirty thousand years later with
Spears you know the first bow and arrow
that we can certify eighteen thousand
years ago that's more that's more
reasonable to say that you found an
arrowhead and from there extrapolate
that this was a bow and arrow again it's
a stretch of the imagination okay so
here's a summary okay know at least what
I think all I can give you a piece of my
mind and you take whatever you want from
it trade here's the breakdown put it up
here okay what problems do I have with
trade well it never happened I'm saying
first issues trust you know you don't
trust the other guy you don't know what
the other guy's gonna do to you he's
gonna kill you he's not gonna trade got
trade you're in life that's what you're
gonna trade then there's nothing to
trade base all hunter-gatherers have
nothing of value to trade okay they take
pride in making their own stuff tools
and weapons they learn from from when
they were little and they walk around
with those weapons maybe they improve
them as they go along or make a new one
but never trade it this is an ocean
comes from today from from service
providers they think they can trade
everything and then for sure basil
hunter-gatherers don't trade food they
hunt their own food and they keep it
they eat it they don't go out there and
say oh I've got too much mammoth meat I
think I'll put it on the market no such
thing no farmers market ok no such
monster you don't go to the other clans
hey
would you like some leftovers that I've
got does it happen then the you get
territoriality you have all these clans
they competed and defended their
territory like a lion Rick defends his
territory no differently and so anyone
who walks in there in fact another clan
from the same species he would be
slaughtered as well okay there were you
know today we fight the Russians fight
Americans fight who fight Chinese you
know of language what are you gonna do
ooh-ho-ho
is that what you're gonna say okay
language is gotta be a barrier and then
you have also the cultural differences
one could be nomadic which would be pro
magnin and nanda throws more sedentary
they were in their own territory okay so
yeah I got a problem with uh with trade
tremendous problem anyone who brings up
trade well I have to treat them with I
treat them for Sicily I can't take them
seriously what is it I have another one
here and then admixture which is the
other big issue that this guy these guys
asked about I have wrongs without it as
well it never happened no other animal
trust you don't trust because if you
trust that's it for you so female from
one clan does not have sex with those
are the different species okay even
within species we have problems lions
you know the the way Lions do it they
they have to go out of the the Father
kicks the son out of the pride with us
son walks out of there because he knows
he can't stay for long and then he finds
a female out there who did the same
thing just got out of her pride that's
one way of doing it the other one is the
lion can kill another lion and take over
the pride there's different ways of
doing it out there in the in the wild
and that's within the same species let
alone between species it never happens
between species and people don't
understand that they think that because
in a zoo you can put a I don't know a
zebra and a donkey together that oh yeah
it could have happened out there no it
never happened in the wild okay partly
because there's no trust okay
Batesville hunter-gatherers they have a
clan structure we have the
territoriality issue you know they
compete and fight they make war not love
it's always war okay there's the issue
shouting range you know a female would
not walk out into the middle of nowhere
where she has no protection she has no
911 from her own clan and again the the
issue there with the with the shouting
is that that's the her 900 oh you know
that's what it happened she can't go
beyond shouting distance she's not gonna
get lost because I mean in in these
service societies people are too stupid
to understand this but in in the wild
you know you don't get lost from your
clan because that's your protection
that's your nine own run that's your
police that's those are the guys who's
gonna defend you so you know they be
stuck together and they know how to
protect themselves because not only
could there be a hare reconnected and so
you know you got to stick together and
you can't walk too far away from your
clan because you have no protection and
another animal can kill you
so people are not stupid you you know
the basal hunter-gatherers they were not
stupid they knew how to take care of
their selves and certainly none of these
service providers of today know how to
take care of themselves because they
think man when one is you know they just
lift the phone and call the police or
whatever I don't know what they have
going through their minds so now you
gotta be within shouting range you can't
be - or some other signal that you could
give to your clans clothes we wore
clothes because we invented the needle
you know and we invented the needle
around the time we entered Europe and we
had to invent the needle because we
recall we were not used to the cold so
when we went into Europe we did put furs
on and and athos they had no no needles
we never found needles among them and
you need to sew things together in order
to protect yourself if you need it but
if you live there for a hundred thousand
years two hundred thousand years three
hundred thousand years I'm sure you're
gonna get used to the cold and build a
layer of fat underneath your skin and
for sure I'm almost sure even though I
can't prove it obviously that the
Neanderthals were furry creatures just
like
you know the mammoth is a furry creature
whereas the elephant is not and they
were gorillas they had hares for sure
all over look more like the guy in 1909
and the guy in 2013 for sure language
big problem for it mixture how do you
say hey dick honey I love you would you
like to have sex with me how do you talk
to another species in fact I don't even
think that all the cro-magnons had the
same language okay keep that in mind you
find another client out there they speak
a different language you go oh and they
go oh uh so how do you understand them
science at sign language so the that's
another issue culture also if one is
nomadic the element sedentary that also
stops it interferes with the admixture
theory no mitochondrial DNA no white
chromosome and Cremona I'm saying
entered thirty-five thousand years ago
anthill disappeared apparently
disappeared earlier I think that as
Neanderthals were dying the other guys
were entering thousands of years where
one was imploding the other was
expanding that's the way I look at
things is this all ground in stone
should you take it to the bank no I'm
saying that anything related the
paleontology should we take should be
taken with a pinch of salt all I can
tell you is my theory and that's that
the Nandor thoughts died all on their
own it had no help from man they died
when their population pyramid overturn
and they lost their genetic diversity
that's the same way Heidelberg died
that's the way same way antecessor died
and that's the same way that Homo
erectus died they disappear when their
population pyramid overturns
and genetic disappears genetic diversity
disappears that's my 10 cents worth take
it to the bank or keep it to yourself
but that's that's my contribution and
yes I will see you on Sunday I'll be
talking this time around you
talking about my favorite subject which
is Michio Kaku